[Musica]
diversi anni fa ho letto il piccolo
principe di antoine de saint exupéry un
testo francese che trovo assolutamente
delizioso tra le pagine di questo libro
ci sono tutta una serie di disegni che
non sempre sono così tanto esplicativi
tra questi ce n'è stato uno che mi ha
colpito particolarmente
ovvero quello di un cappello che in
realtà non era un cappello ma era un po
a chi aveva mangiato un elefante o
addirittura avrebbe potuto essere anche
un elefante sotto un cappello da quel
momento ho iniziato a riflettere
parecchio su come le cose spesso non
sono così come appaiono e quanto le
nostre percezioni possono condurci anche
a quelle che sono delle interpretazioni
sbagliate della realtà e allora mi sono
chiesta potrebbe essere molto più utile
guardare la realtà con prospettive
differenti in modo da poterne vedere
quelle che sono tutte le diverse
sfaccettature
dopo qualche anno studiando psicologia e
ho scoperto che è uno psicologo di
oxford edward de bono ha capito che è un
problema poteva essere osservato da
angolazioni differenti angolazioni che è
in realtà andavano a sovrapporsi a
quella che è la modalità tradizionale di
risoluzione di un problema cioè diretta
unica in questo caso tutte quelle che
sono le sfide dell'esperienza quotidiana
potrebbero essere affrontate con
prospettive che vanno a direzionarsi
verso traiettorie differenti e non
seguendo solo una linea retta a questo
proposito mi verrebbe a questo punto di
chiedervi di attenzionare un attimo
quello che è un enigma
se c'è un cesto con sei uova e ci sono
sei persone e che possono prendere un
nuovo a testa com'è possibile che alla
fine rimanga un nuovo all'interno del
cesso quando cerchiamo delle soluzioni
dei problemi
i nostri neuroni si attivano creando
delle connessioni
e spero che i neuroni di qualcuno di voi
si siano attivati così tanto da poter
arrivare a quella che è la soluzione più
plausibile a questo enigma ovvero che
probabilmente una di queste sei persone
è andata via con il cesto con dentro
l'uovo
ecco in questo caso stiamo parlando
proprio di quello che viene chiamato
lateral thinking o meglio detto il
pensiero laterale perché vi sto
raccontando tutto questo perché l'ambito
della ricerca scientifica e nello
specifico quella cui appartengo ovvero
la ricerca clinica pulsa di pensiero
laterale semplicemente perché cerca di
trovare quelle che sono delle nuove
metodologie che validi no strumenti che
possano essere affidabili innovative e
soprattutto efficaci per poter andare al
supporto a quelle che sono delle persone
che hanno delle difficoltà di tipo
clinico in questo caso se penso a quelle
che sono le soluzioni laterali
nell'ambito della ricerca clinica non
possono pensare alle terapie digitali
quando si parla di terapie digitali
parliamo di tutti quegli strumenti
tecnologici e informatici che permettono
di trovare di migliorare quella che è la
gestione la prevenzione il trattamento
di condizioni fisiche e mentali e
comportamentali che impattano in maniera
importante su quella che è la qualità
della vita della persona
l'obiettivo in questo caso delle terapie
digitali diventa quello di rendere
autonomo il paziente di essere
responsabile del proprio processo di
cura e quindi in questo caso anche
essere coinvolto senza però non
considerare il fatto che questo tipo di
processo importante che sia
individualizzato e personalizzato su
quella che è la personalizzazione della
del processo di cura
voglio fermarmi solo un momento
semplicemente perché lo ritengo un
qualcosa di veramente molto importante
se io dovessi andare se tutti noi
dovessimo andare da un medico
che abbiamo una condizione fisica che ha
bisogno di essere attenzionata e questo
medico dovesse darci una terapia
farmacologica una terapia di tipo
clinica senza andare a considerare
quelli che sono i nostri affetti i
nostri aspetti personali
i nostri valori personali quindi intendo
valore di pressione sanguigna o
addirittura valore cardiologico e quanta
possibilità avremmo che quel tipo di
trattamento possa essere adeguata alla
nostra condizione quindi quanto potrebbe
essere efficace
ecco in questo caso a questa domanda
risponde uno degli ambiti delle terapie
digitali ovvero quello della gestione
della prevenzione della condizione
clinica
a questo proposito voglio condividere
con voi un'esperienza in cui sono stata
coinvolta relativa ad un progetto
europeo in cui mi sono occupata più del
supporto psicologico di un gruppo di
pazienti con scompenso cardiaco
l'obiettivo di questo progetto era
quello di seguire e di guidare questi
pazienti nelle loro abitudini quotidiane
venivano monitorati attraverso un'app
che veniva implementata su un telefono e
in questo caso avevano un feedback
continuo di quello che era il loro stato
di salute in quel momento è di quelle
che potevano essere le scelte di tipo
comportamentale rispetto alla situazione
in cui si trovavano per quanto riguarda
invece tutto l'aspetto legato al
trattamento individualizzato di
condizioni cliniche specifiche e le
terapie digitali soprattutto nell'ultimo
periodo si sono ben integrate con quelli
che sono protocolli di trattamenti più
di tipo psicologico o di tipo
psicoterapeutico in questo caso mi
piacerebbe pensare che a un certo punto
tutti noi facciamo un gioco più di di
ruolo
quindi pensiamo di essere di immaginare
di essere tutti fobici avere una fobia
ben specifica cioè quella di volare
quindi di stare su un aereo
in questo caso se ti può aiutare
posso raccontarvi un'esperienza che ho
vissuto sulla mia pelle per lavoro sono
costretta o per fortuna o per sfortuna
potrei dire a viaggiare parecchio nella
tratta tra catania e milano un
passeggero mi ha chiesto la cortesia di
tenergli la mano solo era quello che
rende collo
allora sia per una deformazione
professionale ma soprattutto per un
empatia più di tipo umano o ha
consentito
morale della storia mi sono ritrovata da
mano stritolata per tutto il tempo e la
persona che ha pianto ininterrottamente
per tutto il tempo del volo dicendo che
l'aereo sarebbe caduto
da un momento all'altro sarebbe
precipitato in questo caso
immaginiamo che noi siamo proprio quella
persona quel passeggiare siamo stanchi
di vivere questa ansia ogni volta che
dobbiamo prendere un aereo è così
decidiamo di seguire un percorso un
percorso ben preciso di psicoterapia un
percorso di psicoterapia che potrebbe
andare da fare tutta una serie di
percorsi in immaginativo dove dobbiamo
condividere con il professionista quelli
che sono sensazioni emozioni i pensieri
durante l'immaginazione di essere
all'interno di un aereo e poi
successivamente di essere esposti dal
vivo quindi andare in aeroporto prendere
un aereo e capire se i livelli di ansia
si sono abbassati
ecco immaginiamo che la terapia digitale
ci permette di essere in mezzo a queste
due fasi del trattamento ovvero non
essere assolutamente catapultati in
quella che è una situazione che potrebbe
creare sicuramente altra ansia
immaginando che comunque una volta
saliti sull'aereo non possiamo più
scendere quindi il nostro pensiero che
il call che l'aereo calda possa essere
lì dietro l'angolo
in questo caso avremo l'opportunità
attraverso un semplice o colusso che è
una mascherina che ci dà l'opportunità
di stare a livello sensoriale dentro
tutti quelli che sono gli scenari che
potessero che potrebbero ricreare l'idea
proprio dall'interno di un aereo ecco in
questo caso la terapia digitale ci
aiuterebbe ad essere accompagnati ad
abituarci a quello che un contesto che
ci fa paura e quindi in questo caso
essere un ponte tra quello che possiamo
immaginare alla realtà potrei anche
farvi un altro esempio ultimamente sta
avendo tantissima efficacia il
trattamento legato più ai disturbi dello
spettro autistico
con protocolli che vengono mediati dai
robot questi robot in realtà non sono
altro che giocattoli attraverso i quali
i bambini imparano delle abilità delle
strategie che poi possono essere messe
in atto in quelli che sono dei contesti
sociali sociali reali e protocolli che
sono stati implementati che soprattutto
sono anche abbastanza recente recenti in
letteratura hanno proprio fatto vedere
quanto i primi step di questi interventi
vedevano gruppi di bambini che tra loro
non riuscivano a comunicare neanche con
lo sguardo e successivamente negli
ultimi step è invece riuscire anche a
scambiarsi quelle che erano non solo
delle informazioni ma anche dei
giocattoli
quindi i robot in questo caso e sono
stati dei mediatori sociali che hanno
permesso la relazione a questo punto
quindi le terapie digitali potrebbero
essere qualcosa che si ritrova sotto
quel cappello del piccolo principe un
qualcosa di nuovo un qualcosa che magari
non non vediamo ma che abbiamo
l'opportunità di immaginare e che ci dà
anche la possibilità di trovare nuove
traiettorie di risoluzione di quelle che
possono essere dei problemi in questo
caso fino a qualche anno fa neanche io
avrei immaginato nel mio piccolo
ambulatorio di poter utilizzare uno
strumento che avrebbe aperto le porte a
la psicologia alla clinica in generale
alla medicina e magari aver dato tante
tante soddisfazioni come sta succedendo
negli ultimi anni